-My first guest is the star of
"The Handmaid's Tale,"
which returns to Hulu
April 28th.
Here is Elisabeth Moss!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh! I'm so happy to see you.
Yeah!
Oh! I'm so happy to see you.
Thank you so much for
doing our show, pal.
-Oh, my God.
Thank you so much for having me.
It's so nice to see you.
-I know. It's good to see you.
There's a lot to talk about.
I want to talk about
"Handmaid's Tale."
But, first, I know you're
a giant Cubs fan,
a Chicago Cubs fan.
And you just finished filming
a movie with one of
the biggest Cubs fans
I know, Bill Murray.
-Yes.
-What -- Did you guys both,
like, go full-on fandom or...
-Bill Murray, for a Cubs fan --
he's like a God.
Like, he's not just a Cubs fan.
He's more important than most
players on the Cubs.
-Yeah, they love him.
Absolutely. Yeah.
-I didn't have the guts to
bring the Cubs up to him
until, literally, I was, like,
walking out with my bag,
and I ran into him
and I was like,
"If I don't say something to
him, I'm gonna regret it."
-Yeah.
-And then I kind of blacked out
and I just became a total moron
and was like,
"Uh, yeah, uh, Cubs are great.
I'm a, you know, Cubs fan.
Uh, yeah, they're
doing good this year."
It was so pathetic.
-He was like, "What's going on?
What are you saying?"
-He was so nice.
I'm sure he was like,
"What is she talking about?"
-Yeah.
-He was so lovely, though.
-You've done high-pressure
things at Cubs games,
including something
I don't think I would ever do.
You threw out the first pitch.
Talk to me about this.
-Yeah.
-Is that nerve-racking?
Why -- I don't understand
why you would do it,
because I'm too afraid of --
Honestly, I would --
Questlove's done it.
It was awful.
-I heard about that.
-Oh, it was terrible.
Like, the Phanatic
was making fun of him.
Everything with the --
But it was like, you know,
Quest is just so lovable.
So, he did it, and that was fun.
But I would be afraid -- I mean,
I'd do it at Yankee Stadium.
I'd be booed out of the city.
-Yeah. I think
I was just excited
to be asked to do
anything by the Cubs.
I would never do it again.
I think they've asked me to do
it again, and I won't.
I've sung the 7th-inning stretch
three or four times.
-"Take Me Out to the Ballgame"?
-Yes.
-That's nerve-racking, too!
I wouldn't do that either.
-That's fine.
I mean, I get a little nervous,
but you have, like, you know,
30,000, 35,000 people
singing with you,
and they don't care.
They don't give
a [bleep] about you.
They're like -- Like,
they're finishing their beer.
They're thinking about
going home.
Like, they don't care.
-They're all drunk.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, "Let's sing a song.
Why not?"
That's true.
-It's like, "What's happening?"
-Yeah.
-They don't care.
So you're kind of just able to,
like, enjoy the experience,
but when I did the pitch,
I also sort of blacked out.
And I was on "Mad Men"
at the time,
so they played
the "Mad Men" theme
when I was walking up to
the mound, which was so weird.
-Yeah.
-But I didn't bounce it.
-You made it over the plate?
Strike?
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
-Amazing. Kudos to you.
I could never do that.
Seriously,
I'm freaking out thinking --
even just thinking about it.
I want to talk to you about
"Handmaid's Tale."
Season 4 is it now?
-Yeah, Season 4. Crazy.
-What can everyone
expect for this season?
-Again, more laughs,
more pratfalls, you know?
-Pratfalls and laughs
in this season.
Oh, my goodness.
-Yep.
Just a lot of bits.
-Wow!
-Surprise celebrity guests
coming in.
"Hello!"
-Yes. Cameos galore.
-Old car horns. Honk-honk.
Stuff like that.
It's "Handmaid's Tale,"
of course.
-You know, the usual.
Yeah, I mean, I do feel like
we have built something
over the past three seasons
that quite rightly
needs to be kind of fulfilled,
and I think that
we do that this season.
With Season 4,
we kind of fulfill a lot of
the promises that we've made
over the last three years,
and we really get to see
not just June,
but a lot of these characters
really go to places
they've never gone before
and change dramatically.
And it's a huge season,
which, of course, we chose to
shoot during a pandemic,
as you do.
-I was going to ask
you about this,
because you made your
directorial debut.
You directed
three of these episodes.
And you chose the craziest time
to direct anything.
Wow! You love pressure.
I think you like these things.
You sing "Take Me Out to --"
You throw out the first pitch.
I mean, why would you choose now
to direct your
first three episodes?
-I do love pressure,
but I didn't choose to --
You know, I chose
to direct the first --
Episode 3 that was going to be
my directorial debut
before COVID and started it.
Then we shut down for
the six months, went back,
and then, all of a sudden,
I did that episode.
I did two more.
I did episodes 8 and 9.
I was like --
Because nobody else
was there a lot of the time,
like, the directors.
Like, if a director finished
their work and left
and they didn't want
to come back
and quarantine for two weeks,
somebody had to direct it.
So, all of a sudden,
I was, like,
the sort of director on hand.
And it would be like,
"Lizzie, we got this, like,
drone shot we need you to do.
Would you mind just, like,
running out and grabbing that?"
-Have you ever done a drone --
What does that even mean?
-No. I don't even know.
-That's great.
-But by the end, we were joking
that I was just gonna be this,
like, journeyman director now,
like, off to do my ninth,
you know, episode of
"Law & Order"
and just
clocking in, clocking out.
-Of course.
I could see more of this.
I'm telling you, man.
I want to show everyone a clip
from an episode
that you directed.
Here's Elisabeth Moss in
"The Handmaid's Tale."
Take a look.
-Well...
it's so wonderful being all
together again, isn't it, yeah?
[ Chuckles ]
-♪ All these things
into position ♪
♪ All these things
we'll one day swallow whole ♪
♪♪
♪ And fade out
again ♪
♪ And fade out ♪
-Yes! That's what I'm
talking about!
Come on!
Yeah, that was great!
Elisabeth Moss!